Hey, what's up guys, it's Pedro here from
New cutter calm. And in this tutorial,
we're gonna learn how to install Node j s, as well
as learn how to actually run code using node j s.
So to get started, we're going to actually have
to download node j s. So if you go to Google and
type node j s download, you should get a web page
similar to this. And I will be leaving a link in
the description in case you can't find it. So go
ahead and download eight, point three lt s. Now
once you download that, run it, install it enjoy
all that good stuff. And within these tutorials,
I'm going to be using Visual Studio code. And
if you don't know what Visual Studio code is,
it's an editor. Now, you can use whatever editor
you want. But the reason I'm using Visual Studio
code is because it has an integrated command
prompt. So once you download these two things,
I'm just going to head over to my desktop.
And let's create a new folder. And I'm just
going to say no JS tutorial. And now I'm just
going to head over to Visual Studio code. And
you should have a welcome screen like this, go to
File, Open Folder. And we are going to open the
folder that we just created. So I'm just going
to select this. And now I'm just going to hit
Ctrl N control and is going to create a new file,
I'm going to hit Ctrl S. And we are going to save
this file. And I'm just going to say app dot j s.
And this is going to be a very, very simplistic
JavaScript file. And we are just going to run it.
And this is just a test to see if you installed
node j s correctly. So if I hit console dot log
hello world, from node j s. Now if I save this,
and I'm actually going to exit out of this, but
you saw that this just popped up on my screen,
if I go to terminal, here is our command prompt.
So I'm just going to exit this to show you how you
can bring this up whenever you want to run code
using the terminal. So I'm just going to close
this. I'm going to hit Ctrl B, I am going to go
to View, I'm going to go to integrated terminal.
Now by default, Visual Studio code has it on
PowerShell. So if I go up here, you can notice
that mine says cmd. So if I hit Ctrl, Shift P and
type default, I can say select default shell. Now
I have three terminals installed on my computer,
you probably have PowerShell, and you probably
have command prompt. And I also have get, go ahead
and click command prompt. hit this plus button,
this is going to bring up a new terminal. So if
I was to hit this or bring up another CMD, and
this should say cmd. So I'm just going to remove
for me, I'm going to remove one, since I already
have one open. And now all I'm going to do is type
node, and then the name of the file. So the name
of the file that we just created was called app
dot j s. And here we go, we get an output of hello
world from node j s. Now let's say that you're
not using Visual Studio code for whatever reason
you have your own editor of choice, what you can
do is you hit the start menu, type cmd and then
go to command prompt. And then you can see that
we get something very similar to the integrated
command prompt, but we're in a different location.
So if I go to my desktop, open this folder. Let's
copy the path that this folder is located. So I'm
just going to hit Ctrl C to copy, head over to my
command prompt. I'm just going to type C the CDs
stands for change directory. All that means is hey
change folder. So right now I am in a folder
called users Pedram makhado. I need to be in
this folder. So now I'm just gonna click this. Go
down to edit, click paste. And that's our path. So
now if I hit Enter, you can see that our path has
changed. And now if I type node app.js You can see
that we get a Hello World from node. So either way
is fine. If you want to use Visual Studio code and
its integrated terminal, you're more than welcome
to, if you're using a different editor and it
doesn't have its own integrated terminal, you're
more than welcome to use the command prompt.
In this tutorial, we're going to be talking about
node modules, or a node module is is basically
a JavaScript file. It's a way to separate
concerns for our application. So for example,
let's say that I have an app.js file. And in
this app.js file, I have maff, a bunch of API
requests and database calls. Instead of putting
them all on one file, what we can do is separate
each of those concerns into their own files. So
to get started, I'm just going to hit Ctrl. B,
I'm going to say Ctrl N. So we're going to create
a new file. And I'm just going to say Ctrl S and
we're going to save it as the tutorial, dot j s.
Let's save that Ctrl B. And now we could focus on
this new file or this new module called tutorial
dot j s. So to get started, let's actually give
our tutorial module something. So I'm going to
give it a function. So I'm going to say const,
some, and it's going to have two parameters, and
all it's going to do is add and return them. So
number one plus number two. Next, what I want to
end up doing is I want to expose this function
to the outside world. Because right now, if I hit
Ctrl S, and if I was to try to use this function,
so I'm just going to delete this. So if I was
just to say sum, one plus one. And if we were
to actually run this, you can see that we get
an error, some is not defined. So you might be
saying, why is some not defined, I just defined it
here. Well, I need to expose this function for the
outside world to use. So I need to let know know
that this sum function within my tutorial module
is available to be used. So in order to do that,
or I need to do is type module exports, and pass
it in some like so. Now that this is available to
be used, I need to tell my app.js file where this
sum function is located. So what I can do here
is declare a variable. So I'm just going to say
Kant's. tutorial. And now I'm just going to use
the word require. And then we're going to give
it a path. Now the path is dot forward slash.
So where did I get dot forward slash from? dot
forward slash means that it's within the same
exact path that this file is currently in where
app dot j s. So if I was to hit Ctrl, B, you
can see that I that j s is on the same level
as the tutorial dot j s, and that they're in the
same folder called Node JS tutorial. So if I hit
Control V, again, get rid of that. And then I
pass in the name of the file, which is obviously
tutorial dot j s. Now you do not need to pass in
the extension, all you need to do is pass in the
name of the file, Node. js automatically assumes
that it is a JavaScript file. And now, if I was to
print out tutorial, two, let's see what's inside
it. And now let's get rid of our son call. We're
gonna call some a little bit later, I just want to
show you what the variable tutorial has. So if I
was to save this, and let's scroll down, I'm going
to type CLS, hit enter. That's going to clear
the terminal. And now I'm just going to run node
app. And you can see that the tutorial now holds
a function called sum from our tutorial module. So
now if I want to actually use that function, I can
say tutorial and pass in one plus one. And let's
actually print out the results. I'm just gonna say
console dot log it. Let's save it, execute it
again. And you can see that we get our desired
output of too and that we are indeed importing
from our tutorial module, the sum function. So now
that we know how to do that, how will we import
ml To pull stuff from modules. So for example, if
we head back to our tutorial module, let's say I
have multiple functions or multiple variables, or
even a class, how do I export more than one thing?
Well, what you can do is I can say, and just for
the sake of example, let's add more stuff. So I
could say Kant's. Hi, and just gonna set this the
3.14. And let's create a class. And I'm gonna say
some math object. Let's give it a constructor. And
I'm just gonna say object created. Okay, so now
I have some pi and some math object. Now, I want
all three of these to be exposed to the outside
world. So that app.js, for example, can require
them and then use it. So how do I do that? Well,
one way to do that is to add properties to the
module dot exports object. So for example, I could
say dot sum. And I'm just going to copy this. So
now experts, that sum is going to have the sum
function exports.pi is going to hold the value
of 3.14. So I just set it equal to pi. And some
math object, it's going to be madrona exports dot
some math object is going to be equal to some math
object. Now if I was to save this, head over to
app, and let's just remove this for now, I want to
print out what tutorial is holding once we require
from our tutorial module. So if I save this, and
now let's execute this, you can see that we're
getting an object back tutorial is now an object.
And now this object has the properties of sun. And
it tells you that it's a function, pi, the value
of pi, and some math object. And you can see that
it's our class. And now if I want to execute this,
it will be like accessing a normal object. So for
example, we have tutorial. And let's say we want
to use the sum function. So just saying tutorial,
and I'm passing the two numbers, I could say
tutorial, sum, and pass in the two numbers. And
I'm just going to copy this. Let's paste this
two more times. And now if I want to print pi,
package, say tutorial, pi. And within here, the
same thing for the object, I can say new tutorial,
dot some math object. And that's going to create
a new instance of our some math object. And now
if I was to save this, and run it, you can see
that it executes as expected. So tutorial sum,
gives us to pi has the value of 3.14. And you
can see that our constructor gets executed
object created. One more thing to show you before
I wrap this up, if this is an ugly syntax for you,
for example, saying module dot exports, that sum
equals this module.exports.pi is a bit repetitive,
what we can do is, instead of exporting each of
these individually, I'm going to let's remove two
of them. And instead, what we can do is export
an object literal and tag along the properties.
So I could say sum is going to be some pie.
This is going to be pi. And then some math
object is going to be some math object. And
if I'm to save this, and now execute it, we
should get the same exact result. So let's execute
that. You can see that it's working beautifully.
And this tutorial, we're going to be talking
about the events module, particularly the event
emitter class within the events module. Now all
the events module allows us to do is basically
bring Event Driven Programming to node j s. So
to get started, we're going to actually have to
require the events module. Now the events module
is actually built into node j s. So I'm just
going to say Kant's. Event emitter. Now this is
going to be the class that we get from requiring,
from the events module, I was just gonna
say equals require event. Now from here,
we're going to have to create a new instance of
the event emitter. So I'm just going to say const,
event emitter, I say, new event emitter.
So from here, we're going to start getting
into Event Driven Programming. Now that I have
my event emitter object, let's actually attach
a listener to it. So I'm just going to say event
emitter. And I'm going to call the method on now,
this method takes on two arguments. One is the
listener that you want to attach to this object.
So I'm just going to call it tutorial for this
example. And the second argument is going to be
the function that you want to execute. When does
the tutorial event occurs. So let's just pass in
this function. And I'm going to say is console dot
log tutorial event has occurred. So now if I save
this and run it, so I'm just gonna hit Ctrl S to
save. And I'm just gonna say node app, you can see
that nothing happens within our terminal. Now, why
is that? Well, I have this object. I've attached a
listener call tutorial. But I haven't emitted
a tutorial event. Remember, this code here,
is only going to be executed when a tutorial event
occurs. So now let's emit a tutorial event. So I'm
just going to say event emitter. And now I'm just
going to pass in tutorial as the first argument.
And that's it. So now, if I was to hit Ctrl,
S to save, and now execute this one more time,
you can see that our tutorial event gets triggered
whenever we call the emit method. So now what
happens when we actually want this function to
have parameters? Well, I could give a parameter
so I could say num, one, num, two. And just for
argument's sake, so just to show on the console,
we're going to print out the sum of number one and
number two. So now how would I call it down here
with the emit method? Well, I'll just pass it in
an argument. So I could pass in one, and two. So
if I save this now, and now go to node app, you
can see that we get the value of three. So you
just pass in the argument. Now, this is all fine
and dandy. But how would I create a custom object
which takes advantage of using events? Well, I
could just inherit from the event emitter class.
So for example, let's say that I want to create a
person class. So I say class person. And I could
just extend from the event emitter class. And
now from here, let's give it a constructor. Now
let's call our super function. So I'm just going
to say super. And this is going to allow us to
use that this property within our class. And now
I'm just going to say this, that underscore name
is going to be assigned value name. And now let's
actually pass in name to our constructor. And now
let's give this person class a getter. So I'm just
going to say get name. And all this is gonna do is
just return this dot underscore name. So now that
we have our person class defined, let's actually
create a new instance of it. So I'm just going to
go down here. And I'm just going to say, let Pedro
equals new person. And let's pass in Pedro. And
now here remember, when I say new person, person
extends the event emitter class, which means that
Pedro is also an instance of the event emitter
class. So now I can add a listener to the page
or object so I could just say pedro.on and And
I'm just going to call it name. And we're going
to pass in our function. And I'm just going to
print out my name is so and so. So I'm just gonna
say console. dot log, my name is. And we're just
going to say Pedro dot name. So now that we've
attached our listener, obviously, we're going
to have to call the emit method. So we're gonna
emit the event has occurred. So I'm just gonna say
Pedro dot emit, and we're gonna pass in name. And
now if I was to save this, and now execute this,
you can see that we get the desired output
of my name is Pedro. So that's how you would
extend using the event emitters class. And for our
final example, let's say that we have more than
one person object, so I'm just going to create a
new person, I'm just going to call let's make it
a girl, I'm just going to call her Christina. I'm
going to say new person. And we're going to pass
in Christina. Now let's add a listener to the
Christina object. So I'm just gonna say Christina,
that on name. And you could use a loop for this.
But since I'm only creating two person objects,
that doesn't make sense for this example, but you
can use a loop to do this on one shot. And we are
just going to copy this. paste this in here, I'm
just gonna say, Christina, that name. Alright,
so why did I go there to bother are showing
you that we create it to person objects,
and attach listeners to it? Well, what I want to
show you is that when you emit an event to occur,
the event gets executed synchronously. So for
example, if I say, Pedro, and I say, Christina,
and now if I was to save this, and now execute it,
you can see that these get executed synchronously.
So because Pedro emitted first, Pedro gets
executed first and then our Christina object,
so they get executed in the order that they
admitted in so they execute synchronously.
In this tutorial, we're going to be talking about
the read line module. Now, what the read line
module allows us to do is prompt the user as well
as get user input. So to get started, we're going
to have to require the module. So I'm just going
to say const. reline is equal to require read
line, and this is going to bring in our relying
module. Next, we're going to have to create an
instance of the read line interface by using the
Create interface method. So I'm just going to say
read line dot create interface. And within here is
going to take an object. Now we're going to give
this object two properties. And this is basically
our configuration file. So the first property I'm
going to give it is input. And then we're going
to give it an object. Now this object is called
process not process is a global object. So you
don't have to require it. It's already given to
us by node. And here we're going to say STD. And
now input is going to be the STD in input stream.
And then here, we obviously need an output. So
I'm just gonna say output, and we're going to
give it process that STD out. And that's going to
stand for output stream. Now, when this method is
executed, is going to return our read line or the
face object. So let's save it inside a variable
so we can use it. So I'm just gonna say const RL
is equal to this. Now let's say I want to ask the
user what two numbers added together are equal to.
So for this example, I'm just going to generate
two random numbers between one and 10. So I'm just
going to say let num one equal math floor math dot
random. And we're going to times this by 10. And
we're going to shift that over by one. So this is
going to give us a random number between one and
10. It's copied us twice. Paste that, too. And we
need the answer. So I'm just gonna say less Answer
equal number one plus number two. All right. So
now that we have this, we're ready to ask the
user what these two numbers are equal to. Now in
order to do that, I'm going to use our read line
interface. And our relying interface has a method
called question. So I'm going to say RL question.
Now, the first argument is going to be a string,
the second argument is going to be a function. And
basically, the first argument is going to be the
question we would like to ask the user. So I'm
just gonna say back tick, what is not one plus
num two? Question mark. And I'm just going to
hit enter here, because I want you guys to see
this on one line. And we're going to include our
callback. Now, this function is going to get the
user input as a parameter. So I'm just gonna say
user input. And for now, I'm just going to print
out user input onto the console, just so you guys
can see that it's actually working. So now if
I was to save this, head over to my console type
node app, it's going to say what is four plus two,
I'm going to say banana. And there you go, it
prints out the user input. It's important to
note that if you take a look at our console,
the application is still running. So I'm just
going to hit Ctrl. C to break out of it. And what
we need to do is actually close the read line
interface when we're done using it. So in order
to do that, let's actually add a couple of things.
First thing, I want a new line, right after this
question mark here. So I'm just gonna say forward
slash n. So when I prompt the user, the users
input instead of lining up right next to it,
like so there's gonna be underneath. Alright, so
I fixed that problem. Next thing I want to do is
actually test the user input to see if he actually
got the answer. Correct. So in order to do that,
I'm just going to say, if user input. And it's
always important to trim the users input, if you
ever accept anything from a user, just to get rid
of the trailing whitespace. And we're just going
to say if the user's input is equal to answer.
So if they answer the math question correctly,
I want to close the application. So I could say,
RL dot close. And here, and now if I was to save
this, and now execute the program, so I'm just
going to write node app. And it's going to say,
What is 10 plus four, and I'm going to answer with
14. And you can see that we answered it correctly,
and therefore our application closed. Now, what I
want to do is actually add a listener to the close
event. Now, the read line interface is actually
an instance of the event emitter class. So what we
can do is actually scroll down here. And I'll add
it towards the end. And I want to say our own.on.
And basically, I'm going to say, hey, I want you
to listen for an event to occur, I'm going to say
close. And we're going to give it a callback.
And this function is only going to execute when
we close the reline interface. So now I'm just
going to say console dot log. And basically,
I just want to let the user know that Hey, you got
the correct answer. So I'm just gonna say correct.
So now if I was to save this, and now execute
it, node app, what is six plus three, I'm just
gonna write nine. You can see that correct, gets
printed out onto the console. Now correct gets
printed out onto the console. Because when we
use the method close, it emits the close event.
And since we're listening for a close event, this
callback function gets executed. And on that note,
I better add a semicolon on there. And let's see
that. So now that we handled what happens when the
user inputs correctly, what happens if the user
gets the wrong answer? So in order to do that,
let's create an else statement within our
question method here. So I'm just going to
say else. And what I want to do basically is re
prompt the user. So I'm just going to say rl.com.
That set prop. And set prompt is basically going
to take an argument of string. And it's going to
ask the user, basically what you want to know. So
I'm going to say to the user, incorrect response,
please try again. And let's add a new line here.
And now in order to use the Prop, I actually have
to call it. So the first method is to set the
prop. The second method is going to be to call on
discussing our prompt. So now, I'm just gonna hit
Ctrl. S to save. And now I'm just going to execute
this node app. And he's gonna say what is one plus
five, and I'm going to say banana. And it's gonna
say incorrect response, please try again. Now,
I actually haven't told it what to do once the
user inputs. So let's actually write the code for
that. Now, what I'm going to do is actually add a
listener to our read line interface. So I'm going
to listen for the users input. And the event for
that is rl.on. Mine. And then we're going to pass
it in our callback. Now this callback is going to
have the user's input. And now we're going to
decide what to do once we get the user's input.
So obviously, what we want to do is check if the
user's input is correct. And if it is correct, we
are going to close the application. And now what
happens if it isn't correct, we're gonna say else.
And then I'm going to reset the prompt. So I'm
just gonna say R dot set prop. And I'm gonna say,
let's actually make this more informative. So I'm
just gonna say your answer. And then we're just
going to print out what they wrote. user input,
is and correct. And we're going to build a forward
slash. And before that, I'm just going to say, try
again. So now let's enter. And now remember, once
we set the Prop, we actually have to call it. So
now I'm just going to say RL dot prop. And now if
we just take a look at what we have so far, this
is basically going to give us a loop. So we set
a line event listener. Now when the user enters
input that's going to trigger this line input,
we're going to test to see if what he gave us is
correct. And if it is, we're just going to close
that but patient. And if we close the application
this on close method is going to execute,
it's going to say, correct. So now let's see what
happens if we give it the wrong value. Is it going
to execute the else statement? And it's going
to set the prompt your answer have so and so
is wrong. And that is going to prompt the user
again. And basically, this line event is going to
keep executing until the user enters the correct
input. So let's actually take a look at this in
action. So I'm just going to clear the terminal.
And before I execute, let me just say, intro as to
say, oops, Ctrl S to save. And now I'm just going
to hit node app. And it's gonna say what is one
plus four, I'm going to say banana. Incorrect
response, please try again, I'm going to type
banana again, your answer banana is not correct.
And you can see that this will go on indefinitely.
Now, if I go back up, and let's actually see
what it was, what is one plus four, I'm just
going to type in five. And you can see we get the
output of correct and then exit the application.
And this tutorial, we're going to be talking about
the file system module. Now what the file system
module allows us to do is work with the file
system. And what I mean by that is that it allows
us to create files, read files, delete files,
create folders, stuff like that. So to get started
We're going to have to require the file module
into our project. So I'm just gonna say const Fs
is equal to require Fs. So now that we have the
file system module within our node application,
let's actually use it. Now. If I hit Ctrl, B,
you can see that all I have is my app.js file
within my Node JS tutorial folder. So let's
actually create a file. So this one's gonna
create a file. And we're going to say Fs dot
write file. Now, the first argument is going
to be the name of the file. So I'm just going
to say example, dot txt. The second argument is
what you want to write to the file. So I'm just
going to say, this is an example. And the third
argument is going to be a callback, and this
callback is going to have a parameter of error,
in case anything goes wrong. So I'm just gonna
say error. There we go. So let's actually finish
writing this. So I could say, if error, we're
just going to print out the error. Otherwise,
we can say, file successfully created. So I'm
just gonna write file successfully created. So
now if I was to save this, and let's run this node
app, you can see that we get file successfully
created. And now if I hit Ctrl, V. good not to be
in the console. And when I do that, Ctrl B. Now,
you can see that we have a newly created file
called example, dot txt. And if we look in it,
we see the data that we wrote to the file. Now
that we created this file, let's actually read it,
let's open up and read it. So if I was to say Ctrl
V again, and I'm just going to go to App dot j, s,
and within this else statement, let's put all
this code within here. And now I'm going to say
Fs dot read file. And within here, the first
argument, much like the right file method, is
going to be the name of the file that you want to
read. So I'm just going to say example, dot txt,
the second argument is going to be the encoding
type. Now I'm going to leave this blank because
I want to show you guys what happens when you
don't leave an encoding type. And then the third
argument is going to take a callback function.
And this callback function has two parameters,
it has error, and it has the file that you
actually want to read. Now in here, I actually
want to show you guys what the file looks like.
So we're going to do the same thing that we did
and the right file method, I'm going to check if
there's any errors. And if there are no errors,
I just want to print the file itself. So now if
I was to save this, go to node app. Now you'll
see that the file was successfully created. And
then you see that when we print out the file,
we get this buffer stream. And then we get this
bunch of numbers following it. Now the buffer
stream stores data and binary. Okay. So what we
need to do is specify the encoding type that we
want it to be displayed as. So up here, we're
going to go up here. And I'm just going to pass
in you TF a. So that's the encoding that I want.
And now if I was to save this, go to node app. You
can see that file was successfully created. And
we're successfully reading the contents within the
file. Alright, so now that we know how to create
and read files, let's actually cover a few more
methods. So what I want to do is start with a
fresh examples. I'm just gonna comment this all
out. I'm just going to highlight everything Ctrl
backslash, and that's going to comment everything
out for me. Now what I want to do is let's say
that when I created this example dot txt file,
that I really didn't mean to call example dot
txt, let's say I wanted to call it example to,
for instance, well, I could use the Rename method.
So I could do something like this, I can say Fs
dot rename, and rename is going to take in three
arguments. The first argument is going to be
example, dot txt. And that's going to be the name
of the file that we want to rename. The second
argument is going to be what we want to rename the
file to. So I'm just going to say example two, dot
txt. And the third argument is going to be their
callback function, which has a parameter called
error. And we're going to do the same thing, as
we've been doing for all these asynchronous calls,
we're just going to say, if error, we're just
going to print that out to the console. If there's
no error, and everything went fine, we're gonna
say successfully rename the file. So I'm just
gonna say successfully rename the file. So now,
if I hit Ctrl, S to save, and now let's run this,
you'll see successfully renamed the file.
And it says the leader from this, and that's
probably because it hasn't updated yet. So if I
close this, and I'm just gonna hit Ctrl, B. And
you can see that within our package explorer,
that our file has been renamed to example two,
dot txt. And if I open this as the same exact
file that re created, couple more methods that
I want to go over. So I'm just going to hit Ctrl.
B. And let's say that, once I comment this out,
let's say that when I was creating the file that
I forgot to add something towards the end of the
file, so what do you want to do, I want to append
data to the file. So I'm just going to say Fs that
a pen file is going to take in three arguments,
it's going to take in the name of the file, I'm
just going to say example, two dot txt, the second
argument is going to be the data that you want
to append to the file. So I'm just going to say
some data being upended. And the third argument
is going to be the callback function. And this
is going to have an error as a parameter passes
and, and we're gonna say if error printed out to
the console. Otherwise, we're gonna print out that
we successfully appended data to the file. So I've
successfully appended data to file. I'm just gonna
move this over so you can see. And now if I save
this, and execute this, so node app, you'll see
successfully appended data to the file. So let's
actually take a look at our file. And you can see
that our file has been changed. So before we had
this as an example, and then we appended on data
to the end of the file. And the last method that
I want to cover within this tutorial is how do
I delete a file. So for example, we did all this
and let's say that I've had enough with this file,
I just want it gone. So let's just comment this
out. And this is going to be the final method that
I go over. So we're just gonna say Fs dot unlink.
And the first argument is, obviously, you guys
should get this by now. It's going to be example,
two. Example two dot txt. And the second argument
is going to be a callback function and have the
parameter of error. And within here, if ever
printed out to the console, if there's nowhere
where we're just going to say successfully deleted
the file successfully. So now if I was to save
this, and now execute it, you can see successfully
deleted the file status up here deleted from
this. So if I close this, and if I was to
hit Ctrl B to bring up the package explorer,
you can see that the file I no longer exist.
And this tutorial is going to be part two of
my file system modules tutorial. Now in the
previous tutorial, we went over using the file
system module to work with files. And this I
want to go over how to work with folders. So to
get started, we're going to have to require the
file system module. So I'm just going to say
const, Fs equals require, and then Fs here.
Alright, and now what I want to do is I'm going
to say fs.mk Dir. And what MK dir stands for is
make directory. And our directory is is a folder.
So now here, it's going to take in two arguments,
one is going to be the folder name that you want.
So I'm going to give it the value of tutorial. And
then we're going to pass in the callback with
an error. And we're just going to say if error,
console dot log error, oh, we successfully created
the folder so on so say, console, log folder
successfully created. So now if I was to
save this, and now before actually run this,
I'm just going to hit Ctrl. b. So you don't see
that there's any magic happening. So all I have
is my Node JS tutorial folder, and app.js file. So
now, if I go here, type node app, you can see that
we get the output a folder successfully created
and that our tutorials folder has been created.
Now let's say that I actually want to delete this
folder. So I'm just gonna hit Ctrl V again. And
this is actually going to give us an error, but
I'm just going to show you what the error is,
is basically going to complain that this folder
really exists. So I'm just going to say Fs that
are m, and r M stands for remove, and then dir and
that stands for remove folder. Now I'm going to
give the folder name, so we call it tutorial.
And this is also going to take a callback,
which gets an error. So now if I say if error,
console dot log the error, oh, we're gonna say
successfully deleted the folder successfully
deleted the folder. So now if I was to save this,
and now execute it, you see that we get an error
file already exists. And that's because the
tutorials folder already exists. And we're trying
to create another folder named the same thing. So
I'm just going to hit Ctrl V. Again, delete that
tutorial folder, I'm just going to hit delete,
confirm that Ctrl V again, let's execute this.
And you can see that we successfully deleted the
folder. So if I go up here, hit control B, you'll
see that it doesn't exist. So first thing we do is
we create a folder called tutorial. And then if
this is successful, then we're going to delete
the folder called tutorial. And you can see by
output that we successfully deleted the folder.
Now this is too fast. And that's why you wouldn't
be able to see it if we had the package manager
open. So now that we know how to create and delete
a folder, what I want to do now is create a folder
and then create a file within that folder. So I'm
just going to hit control B. And we can leave this
make directory. So we're going to make a folder
called tutorial. And if it's successful, it's
going to execute this else block. So let's remove
this. And then within here, we're going to create
our new file. So to do that, I'm just going to
say Fs dot write file. Now write file is going
to take in three arguments. It's going to take and
the name of the file, but in this case, we've got
to give it the full path. So I'm going to say dot
four slash. And what dot forward slash means is I
want you to start relative to App dot j s. And
then I want you to go inside the folder called
tutorial. So I'm just going to hit Ctrl B just to
show you. So app dot j s start here. There's going
to be a folder called tutorials. I'm going to go
in inside that folder, tutorial. And now I want
to you to create the file called example, dot txt.
So if I hit Control V again, and then the second
argument is going to be what the data that you
want, I'm just going to write 123 doesn't matter
for this example. And then the third argument is
it going to be a callback function which gets an
error. And then within here, I'm going to write if
error, console dot log the error onto the console.
Oh, we're gonna write successfully created, file,
successfully created file. So now let's save this.
So I'm just gonna hit Ctrl. S, down here, node
app. And you can see that it says successfully
created file down here. So now if I hit control B,
and I'm going to go up here and then hit control
B, you can see that we have our newly created
tutorial folder. And within here, we have our
example dot txt. So if we go in here, you can see
it has the data of one, two, and three. Now, what
I want to show you is, how would I delete a folder
that has a file within it. So you might be saying,
if I just go back here, hit Ctrl B, that can't
I just use Fs dot remove directory in order to
do this. Well, I am actually just going to comment
all this out. And what will end up happening if I
use the Remove directory function is that is that
I'll get an error. And the reason for that is,
because if I use the Remove directory function,
it has to be used on a directory or folder that
is empty. So just to show illustrate this,
that's going on right this quick remove
directory function. And if there's an error print
it else, we're just gonna print deleted folder. So
I'm just going to hit Ctrl S to save. And I'm
just going to type CLS to clear the terminal
node app. And you can see that we get an error
directory not empty, that we're trying to remove
a directory that has a file within it. So in order
to fix that, let's delete the file first. So I'm
just going to say Fs dot unlink. And the first
argument is going to be the file. So remember,
dot forward slash, and then we have to go into
the tutorials folder. And then I named the file
example dot txt. Next argument is going to
be a callback function which has an error,
I'm just going to say if error, print that out.
If there's no error, then what I want to do well,
if there's no error, that means that I
successfully deleted the file, which means
I can now successfully remove the file. So I'm
just going to copy this. And I'm going to put this
within the else block here. Add some semi colons.
And now if I was to save this, and now execute it,
you can see that we have deleted folder. And you
can see up here deleted from this. So if I go
hit control B, you can see that the folders been
successfully deleted. So what did we do? First,
we deleted the file that was within the folder.
And then if that was successful, then I wanted
to delete the folder itself. Last example that I
want to do is what happens when there are multiple
files within a folder, and you want to delete all
those files. So I'm going to cheat a little bit,
and we're just going to create it within our
package explorer. So I'm just gonna say new
folder, and we're gonna call it example. And I'm
just gonna give it two files. I'm just gonna say a
dot txt. And the second file is going to be b dot
txt. All right, so now I have my folder and I have
my two files. So how would I go about doing this?
Well, there's a method called Read directory. And
what read directory does is it gives you back the
list of files that you have within that folder. So
let's actually call it so I'm just gonna comment
on this out. comment this out. And then I'm just
going to type Fs dot read directory. Now the
first argument is going to be obviously the
name of the directory. And in this case, we call
it example. And then the second argument is going
to be a callback function. first parameter is
going to be error. And then second parameter
is going to have files now files is going to
be an array with the name of the file. So now,
we can test if there's an error, all we're gonna
do is print out the error, there is no error,
we're gonna print out files, I'm just gonna print
out files just to show you what files contains.
So if I save this, run this and the console,
you can see that we have our two files stored
within an array, a dot txt, and B dot txt. So now
let's actually loop through this array and delete
everything. So now I'm just going to say for let
file of files. And then within here, we can start
deleting each file individually. So I could say
Fs dot unlink. And then we're going to give it
the file name. So it's going to be dot forward
slash, example, then it's going to be the name
of the file. After that is going to take in an
argument callback for an error. And if there
was a problem deleting that file, it's going to
print it out to the console. If there wasn't,
we're just going to say, successfully deleted
file. So and So So, so successfully. deleted
file. So now if I was to save this, and now
execute this, you can see successfully deleted
file once twice. And if I hit Ctrl, B, you can
see that we have an empty folder called example.
In this tutorial, we're going to be talking about
the readable and writable screens. Now what these
screens allow us to do is basically be able to
read and write data more efficiently. And the
way that they accomplish this is by reading and
writing data, and chunks as opposed to reading and
writing the data all at once. So to get started,
we're going to have to require the FS module or
the file system module. So I'm just going to say
const. fs is equal to require Fs. Now that we have
our file system module included, we're going to
create a readable stream. And there's a method
called Fs dot create reach screen. And now I need
to give it the path. So if I just hit Ctrl, B,
you can see that I have an example dot txt file
here, and it has a bunch of texts that we're
going to be reading in. So if I head back to App
dot j, s, hit Ctrl V, again, we're just going to
give it the path of dot forward slash, example
dot txt. And then that's it. Now this is going
to return to us a readable stream. So I'm just
gonna save it within a variable. I'm just gonna
say cons reach stream is equal to Fs dot read
stream. And then here, what we can do is listen
for an event. Now the return object inherits
from the event emitter class. So that means we
could listen for events to occur. And one event
that we want to listen for is the data event. So
I'm just going to say read stream.on data. And
then this is going to take a callback function.
And now we're going to get a chunk of data and
return. So every time we read a piece of data,
this event data is going to be invoked. So this
callback function is going to be called every
time we get a piece of data. So now I'm just going
to print out the data onto the console. And you're
going to see why I call it a chunk and not the
full file in a second. So now if I save this,
go to node And you can see that we read this data
within two chunks. So we have to print out here,
we have a buffer here, and a buffer here. So
let's actually set the encoding type. So it's
a lot easier to what the sources, and we're just
going to set it to UTF, eight, and save this. And
now let's rerun this application. And there you
go, you see that we read our text file. So what
are the benefits are reading this in a chunk, as
opposed to loading the whole file? Well, for one,
when I get this chunk, I could immediately start
manipulating that chunk. So I don't have to wait
for the whole file to load in order to manipulate
it. Or let's say that I don't want to manipulate
this chunk of data that I got already, I want
to send it to a new file, well, I could start
sending that data to a new file, while I'm reading
in the data itself. So let's actually send it to a
new file. And for that, we're gonna have to create
a writable stream. So I'm just going to go here.
And I'm going to say const. Right stream is equal
to Fs dot create, write stream. And within here is
going to be the name of the file that I want to
write to. So I'm just going to call it example
two dot txt. And now within here, what I can do
is, instead of waiting to get the whole data,
I can start writing chunks to the new file.
So within here, instead of just printing out
console dot log, chunk, I can say, right stream
dot, right. And I could write this data to a new
file as I'm reading it. And so I could say chunk
here. And let's say that. And now if I run this
application node app. So now if I hit Ctrl, B, you
guys see our newly created file. And if I go here,
you can see that we wrote onto a new file. So
basically, what's happening here is I'm able to
write chunk by chunk, and our example two chunks,
in order to get the full file, I'm able to start
writing before the file is fully loaded. And
that's pretty much the power of using a stream.
This tutorial, I'm going to show you guys why you
should be using streams by trying to read a very,
very large text file. So to get started, I'm just
going to show you how big the file is. So I'm just
going to hit Ctrl. B, we have our large file dot
txt file here. And if I click review and explorer,
right click Properties, you can see that the size
it's about 2.7 gigs. So let's actually take a look
at what would happen if we were to use the read
file method from the file system module. So now,
if I was to execute this and type node app, you
see that we get an error and the error says file
size is greater than the possible buffer. Now,
what does that mean? Well, the read file uses a
buffer, but it uses a full buffer. Now what that
means is that I need at least 2.7 gigs in memory,
in order to load this file, because this file has
to be loaded, because this file has to fit within
the buffer. And it's saying, Hey, your buffer
size is just too small for this file. Now, I'm
just going to comment this out. And now what we're
going to use is a readable stream. So I'm just
going to comment this out. And then we're going to
uncomment this. And by the way, I have tutorials
on both readable streams and using the read file
method. So now I have the stream will look what
happens when I execute the code now. So if I was
to save this, and now execute it, you can see
that are readable stream has absolutely no problem
reading this file. So I'm just going to hit Ctrl C
to cancel this, because I don't want it to finish,
you know loading the entire thing. But why can
this be accomplished with streams but not using
this read file method? Well, one, a stream uses a
buffer awesome, but it doesn't use a full buffer.
It uses a very, very small buffer and what That
allows us to do is basically what's happening is
that you're ending out reading the file in chunks,
you're not reading the entire file at once. So
basically, every time a data event occurs, I am
getting a chunk of the file, I'm not attempting
to read the entire file at once. And therefore,
the buffer size could be a lot smaller, as opposed
to a read file method, which uses a full buffer,
which needs to be big enough to load the entire
file at once. And then server streams allow for
smaller buffer size, which is memory efficient.
And for data to be read and written and chunks.
And this tutorial, we're going to be going
over pipes. Now what a pipe allows us to
do is basically take a source stream, which is
just a readable stream, and send it over to his
destination, which is just a writable stream.
So in the last tutorial, we went over readable
streams and writable streams. And basically what
we did was create a read stream. And then from
there, we create a write stream. And then we
attached an event listener to the reach stream.
And every time we got a data event emitted, we
read a piece of the chunk from the read stream,
and then rewrote out that chunk to where we
wanted to send it. So there's actually a much
more simpler way. And the much more simpler way
is just to get rid of this. And all we're going to
do is say restream dot pipe. Now pipe is going to
take what restream gives us and it's going to pipe
it into our right stream. So now if I was to bring
up the terminal, and just type node app, and hit
Ctrl V, you can see we have our example Tex. And
then we created our example two dot txt. So the
pipe method is basically a shorthand version for
all that stuff that we wrote in the last tutorial.
So all we need to remember is, in order to use
a pipe, we need two streams, we need a source
stream. And we also need a destination stream.
In our case, the reach stream is our source,
this is the file that we want to read in, then
we call the pipe method on the retrieve. And then
this is going to take the destination where do we
want to send this data to, and that's to the right
stream. So now I want to talk about pipe chaining.
So let's give a more complicated example. And for
that, I'm going to bring in another module. And
I'm going to bring in Kant's z lib. Now z lib
is a module that is for basically compression,
compressing files, I'm just going to say require
z lib. Now what we're going to do is create a
transform stream. Now, what a transform stream is
basically is what it does is it takes the input.
So for example from our read stream, and then when
it receives that data, it manipulates that data
into something else. And in this case, what it's
gonna do is compress the data. So I'm just going
to create a transform stream. So I'm just gonna
say cons. Gs is equal to z lib dot create jesup
call that method. Now this is going to return
our transform screen. And now within here, a set
of saying reach dream, what I can do is send that
data that reach stream is giving us and I could
pipe it into our Gs. Now what GS is going to do
is take the chunks of data that is reading at a
time, and it's going to manipulate it and compress
it basically. So you're going to get a compressed
version of the read stream. And then from here,
we're going to pipe it out to our destination,
which is our right stream. So now if I was to
run this, let's save it. Now I'm just going to hit
Ctrl B. And if we go here to example, two dot txt,
you can see that we accidentally did not change
the type and that's my fault. So the type that
we're creating create write stream should not be
a txt file. It should be a.gz file and that's the
compression type. So I'm just going to save this
and let's run this application. Again. Now I'm
going to hit Ctrl B. And you can see that we get
an example two.txt.gz file. Now, if I clicked it,
it's going to say that Visual Studio Code cannot
open this. So I'm just going to right click it,
reveal an explorer. And you can see that zip
file is basically a compressed file. And I'm
going to double click it. And you can see that
our example two dot txt files here and with our
tax. So now let's give just one more example just
to get the hang of it, chaining pipes and using
a transform stream. So we saw what happens when
we compress the file and then write it. So let's
go and reverse, we're going to take our source,
which is compressed, we're going to uncompress it,
and then we're going to write it. So from here,
let's just go back to Visual Studio code. Let's
go back to App dot j s Ctrl V. And instead
of saying create jesup, what we want to do
is create unzip. So I'm just going to go here and
say create g unzip. And we're going to change this
variable to unzip. And now this is going to be our
transform stream. So I'm just going to copy this,
paste that here. And now what happened, well,
read stream has changed, right, so now I want
the compressed version of it. So let's go over
here, we're going to get rid of the encoding
type. The compressed file is called example
two dot txt Gz. So I'm just going to copy this,
I'm going to paste this in here. Now this input,
this reach stream is going to be piped to G unzip,
which is going to basically uncompress the
file, and then it's going to send it off to our
destination. So what do we want our destination to
be called, we could pretty much name this anything
you want. So I'm just gonna say uncompressed dot
txt. So now if I was to go ahead and save this
type node app, execute it, we hit Ctrl B. And
you can see that we have our uncompressed txt
file. So if I click this, you can see our example
Texas here, and that is successfully uncompressed.
In this tutorial, we're going to go over the HTTP
module. Now what the HTTP module allows us to do
is basically create a web server with node j s.
So to get started, we're gonna have to require
the HTTP module. So I'm just gonna say const.
HTTP is equal to require HTTP. Now from here,
we can call method called create server. And this
is going to give us a HTTP server object. So I'm
just going to say const server is equal to http
dot create server. Now, this method is going to
take a callback and this callback is going to give
us a request object as well as a response object.
So let's just do that. Now, the request object is
what the client requests from us. So for example,
if I am on Google Chrome, and I type in
www.google.com, I am requesting something
from Google. Now Google server is going to
take that request, and it's going to send me
a response back. So the most simplistic example
that I could give you is I could send a basic
text back to the client. So I could say rez, and
that's going to be my response, I'm going to say,
right, and I'm just going to pass in a string. So
I'm just going to say, Hello world, from node j,
s. Now within here, I haven't actually sent the
response back, I just told it what it is. So in
order to send the response, I'm going to say
res dot. And now this is going to take care of
our HTTP dot create server method. Now there's one
more thing that we have to do to get the server up
and running. And that's the total node j s. What
port that I want to listen for requests that song
is going to say server dot listen. And we're gonna
listen on port 3000. So now if I was to save this,
and now go down, Here type of node app, you can
see that our server is up and running. Now I'm
going to go to Chrome. And within here, I'm going
to type local host, colon, and then the port,
which we assigned was 3000. So that's where
we're listening for requests that if I hit Enter,
you can see that we get a response back
from the server, hello world, from node j,
s. So now from here, what we can do is actually
listen to requests, different routes. So let's
actually take a look at a property of the request
object. And one of the properties is called URL.
So instead of just saying, hello world, from node
j, s, I only want to say hello world from node j.
s, if it is the root domain, so I'm just gonna
say request dot URL is equal to forward slash,
then I'm gonna say res dot write Hello, world
from Node JS. And then don't forget that we
have to send the response back to the client.
So we're going to call resident and and now if
I was to save this, and we're going to is going
to hit Ctrl. C to kick us out of the server. And
then we're going to start the server back
up again. So we get our updated changes,
we're going to go back to Chrome, hit Enter. And
you can see that it works exactly the same. If we
were to add an else statement here. So let's
say they are not using the root domain, aka,
say rez dot write using some other domain, and
then we're going to send that out to the user. And
that's actually Ctrl. C this to stop the server.
And before we start up the server, I have to save
so I'm just gonna say Ctrl. S to save node app.
And now here, instead of localhost colon 3000.
I'm going to say local hosts, banana. And let's
see what response we get. And the response we get
back is using some other domain. Now this response
is going to be for anything we type because we
put it in the else block. So if I type that, I'm
going to get the same response. And then if I go
back and just have the forward slash, you can see
that we get the Hello World from node j s output.
And this tutorial, we're going to be going over
how we can serve static files, using the HTTP
and file system module. So to get started, I'm
just going to hit Ctrl. B to bring up the package
explorer. And you can see that we have a static
folder. And we have three static files. Now, these
files is a JSON file, an image, a PNG file, and an
index dot HTML file. So what I want to do is make
a request to the server and have the server send
these files back to me. So I'm just going to hit
Ctrl B to get rid of that. And the first thing
we're going to do is actually required modules
on this gonna say const, HTTP equal require HTTP.
And then our second module is going to be the file
system modules, I'm just gonna say require Fs.
Now, first step to do this is to actually create
the server. So I'm just gonna say HTTP dot create
server. And this is going to take a callback,
and we're gonna have a request object and a
response object. Now I'm going to call a method on
that server object. So I'm just going to say that
listen, and we're going to listen on port 3000.
Now, let's say that I want to read in a HTML file,
for instance. So let's go up here. And what I can
do is create a readable stream. So I'm just going
to say can't reach dream, it's going to be equal
to Fs. dot create, reach dream. And then within
here, we're going to pass in the path. So I'm
going to say dot forward slash, because it's going
to be relative to App dot j s. Now I need to go
inside the static folder. And then the name of the
file that I want read in is called index dot HTML.
Now what I want to do is actually write a header
for my response. Now what a header is responsible
for is the let the client know what kind of data
that I am expecting. So I'm just gonna say rez,
that right head. And then within here, we're
going to pass in the HTTP status code. So
I'm going to pass in 200. Now 200 means that
everything went okay with your request. And
then the second argument is going to be what the
content type, so I'm just going to hit content
type. And then we're gonna pass in text slash
HTML. All right, so now that we've written our
header, I'm just going to take you guys to Google
Chrome real quick just to look up the status
codes. Now you can see that HTTP 200 means that
the request has been successfully completed. So
whatever the user requested from the server, that
means everything went fine, as I said, and there's
a bunch of HTTP status code. So let's look at
another one. So another common one is four, four.
So you're going on a website, and you accidentally
Miss type the URL and they give you a not found
error. So that would be a 404 error. Now, let's go
back to our Visual Studio code. And let's complete
this, I'm just going to go down here. And within
here, I'm just going to pipe the reach stream into
where I want to send it. So I'm just going
to say reach stream dot pipe. And where do I
want to send this file, I want to send it to the
user. So I'm going to pass in rez, now read the
response object is also a writable stream. So I'm
piping it to the response object. So now I'm just
going to save this. Let's go back to Chrome. I'm
going to go here, Google, and I'm going to type
localhost 3000. And I should probably be noted
that you should start up your node applications,
I'm just gonna type node app. Now let's go back to
Google Chrome, hit refresh. And you can see that
our HTML file has been successfully sent. So let's
actually try to send the other static files. And
this was pretty much straightforward. So all we
have is if I hit Ctrl, B is an image and a JSON
file. So I'm just going to hit Ctrl V, again,
now all we need to do is obviously change the
file that we're reading in. So instead of index
dot HTML, let's do example dot JSON. Now I'm the
content type is obviously not a text slash HTML
file. So we're gonna have to pass in application
slash JSON. And now, if I was to save this, hit
Ctrl C, so we're going to restart the server, I'm
just going to clear out the terminal node app. Now
let's hit refresh. And you can see that our JSON
file gets loaded and sent to the client. Now let's
load up that image. So now the same exact thing,
I'm just going to hit Ctrl B, because I forgot
when I named the image, I named it example dot
png. So I'm just gonna change this to P and G. And
instead of application dot JSON, we're gonna just
gonna remove this. And we're just going to go here
and type image slash PNG. So now if I was to save
this, now, we got to restart the server Ctrl C to
cancel that out, no app. Now, if I go to Chrome,
hit refresh, you can see that my image has been
loaded. So that's basically the ins and outs
of how you would serve a static file using the
HTTP module, as well as the file system module.
In this tutorial, we're going to be going over
how we can create our package dot JSON file.
Now what the package dot JSON file is responsible
for is basically holding all our metadata for our
project, metadata being the name of the project,
the version number, etc. So to get started,
what we're going to use is called the node package
manager. So I'm just going to type NPM And then
I'm going to type in net, which means initialize,
I hit Enter. And you'll see that we get a bunch of
jargon. So what do we want to name, the package,
by default is going to be called the name of the
folder that you're currently in. So up here, you
can see no GS underscore tutorial. And it says the
default will be no GS slash tutorial. So I could
just hit enter, that's fine with me the version
number 1.0 dot zero, that's okay. Description.
So what is this package about? What is your
project about? And we're just gonna say tutorial,
because that's what we're using it for. And then
the entry point is pretty important. And it lets
us know which file should be used to start our
node application. So for example, if I was making
a website and uploaded to a server, it will let
the server know that that was our entry point
to our application. Test command. Let's ignore
that for now. Enter, and Git repository is pretty
self explanatory. Is it going to be your Git URL,
hit enter keywords, we're gonna leave that blank
as well. Author, go ahead and write down your
name. license is C as defined by me, then it's
gonna say Is this okay? And we're just gonna say,
yeah, that's fine. So you might think that
nothing has happened. But if I hit Ctrl, B,
you can see that we have our package dot JSON
file created. And if I take a look at this,
open it up, you can see that package dot JSON is
just a JSON file. And it has our configuration
setting. So the name, the version description of
our application, the entry point, scripts, author,
and license. And basically, in the next tutorial,
what we're going to end up doing is actually
going out and installing external packages
and including them within our own project.
This tutorial, we're going to be going over to
node package manager in order to install packages.
Now our package is is basically reusable code that
we can include within our own application, it's a
folder with one or more modules within it. So to
get started, we're actually gonna head over to
Chrome real quick. And there's actually a website
called NPM, J s.com. Now NPM, J s.com is where
we can actually look and discover new packages
that we can include within our application. So
I'm just going to pick out a package, and we're
going to install it and then use it. So I'm just
going to scroll down. And you could use the search
up here. Or, let's just pick a popular package.
So you can see packages that a lot of people are
installing. and scroll down more. And let's pick
lower das. And then here, we're given a bunch of
instructions. So it says in order to install this
package, I just have to type in this command NPM
i i in shorthand for install, and then the name of
the package. So in this case, the packages name is
lodash. So if I head back to Visual Studio code,
and I type NPM, install lodash. You can see that
it goes out, and it downloads the package for me
automatically. And now if I head back to my
package dot JSON file, the JSON file that we
created in the previous tutorial, you'll notice
that we have an extra property. And within this
property is called dependencies. And then it
gives us the name of the package we installed,
as well as the package version that we installed.
So now if I was just to hit Ctrl, B, you would see
that we have a extra folder and this extra folder
is called node modules. So if I opened this up,
you can see that our lodash installation is
stored here within this folder. So now this
is all fine and dandy, but how would I now
use lodash within my own personal project,
so I'm just going to hit Ctrl B. And we're going
to close out our package dot JSON file. And we're
going to go to App dot j s and basically what
we're going to do is require it so I'm just
gonna say cool. underscore is equal to require
lodash. And now from here, let's actually use
it to prove that this is working. So I'm just
going to say underscore dot fill. And fill is
basically going to take an array. So I'm just
going to pass in an array 12345. And the second
argument is going to take an A value, what do you
want to replace these numbers were, so I'm just
going to say banana. And the third argument is
going to be the start index. So what I want to
do is start at index one. And the last argument is
going to be the end index. And since we have five
elements within our array, the last index would
be four. So let's actually store this within a
variable. So I'm just going to say let example is
equal to that. And we're just going to print out
this onto the console. So I'm just going to hit
Ctrl S to save when I go to node. And you'll see
that we require lodash into our application. And
we've tested that one of the methods within lodash
is actually working. So we get a new array, and
we filled in index 123 with the value of banana.
And let's say that for whatever instance that you
installed the wrong module, or you want to get rid
of a module, so if I hit control B, and we're just
going to bring up the package dot JSON file and
hit Ctrl V again, what I can do is I can say
NPM, uninstaller, and then the package name,
which is going to be lodash. And you can see
that lodash is removed from our dependencies.
And if I hit Ctrl V, you can see that our node
underscore modules folder no longer exists.
And that's because we have no dependencies
that our application is using currently.
In this tutorial, we're going to be talking about
semantic versioning. Now, what semantic versioning
is, is basically just a standard that a lot of
Node JS packages follow and allows for us to
know what kind of changes have occurred, and the
updated version of the package. So to get started,
you can see that I have my package dot JSON
file open. And I have a dependency install
called lodash. Now within here, you see the
version of the package that I installed with
the carrot sign. And we'll talk about the carrot
sign within this tutorial as well. But for now,
I want you to focus on these three numbers. The
first number four is going to represent the major
version of this package, the second number is
going to represent the minor version. And the
third number is going to represent the patch
version. Now the major minor and patch numbers
all have different meanings. So for example, right
now, the latest version is four point 17 dot 11.
If I wake up tomorrow, and lodash is updated, and
it says the latest version is four point 17 dot
12. That means that that was a patch update. Now
all I patch update means is that they implemented
some bug fixes. Now likewise, same thing happens,
I go to sleep, they update lodash tomorrow,
and instead of four point 17 dot 11 is four point
18 dot 11. So that means that there was a minor
update. Now when a minor update does is it adds
new functionality. And it might deprecate some of
the old functionality, but you could still use it.
So it's a non breaking change update. And finally,
if I was to go to sleep tomorrow and wake up new
version of lodash is updated. And this time we
get version 5.0 dot zero. So what does that mean?
That means that there was a major update pushed
out to lodash. And what a major update indicates
is that there was a breaking change. So that means
version 5.0 dot zero is not compatible with the
code four point 17 dot 11 or any version of four.
So now let's talk about this carrot character. And
this carrot character was put there automatically
When we type NPM, install lodash. Now what this
carrot character symbolizes the following. So the
following rules, if you will. So this means
that whenever I use the carrot character,
that I do not want you to make any major
updates. So that means right now I'm on
version four as the major. But if there is a
minor update, or a patch update, go ahead and
download those new packages. Now, there's another
symbol called the tada symbol and total symbol is
right next to the number one on your keypad.
And that means that you want the following to
occur. That means you only want patch updates.
So let's say I'm on four point 17. Right now,
that means I only want you to change the last
number. So for example, if for Part 18 comes out,
this total symbol will say, hey, do not update
to that package. And last but not least, let's
say that you don't want the tilde or the carrot
sign up here. So for example, you don't want the
carrot sign to update the minor or the patch. And
you don't want the Tilda to just update the patch,
what you can do is remove the carrot or the
tilde a sign. And this guarantees that the
only version of lodash that you will ever have
within your package will be four point 17 dot 11.
In this tutorial, we're going to set up our first
Express server. Now all Express is is basically
a web framework for node j s. So in the previous
tutorials, we use the HTTP and file system module,
in order to serve static files. With Express,
however, you can see that we can accomplish
that and much more with much less code. So to get
started, I'm just going to go over to Chrome. And
here is Express jSs official website. So you
can see up here that they have guides for you,
you could reference the API. And basically, this
is just the documentation for Express. And you can
see that they give install instructions here. Now,
if you didn't go to the official website, or you
didn't know that they had an official website,
he probably would have went to NPM j s calm,
that Express is a publicly available package for
you to download and install. And you would have
just typed Express within the search bar here.
So I'm just going to head back to Visual Studio
code. And the first thing that we need to do is
actually create our package dot JSON. So I'm just
gonna say NPM and net, and I'm going to pass in
the flag, yes. Now, when you pass in the flag,
yes, you basically skip all these configuration
questions that they ask you when you type NPM. And
net. So now that we have our package, JSON, we can
actually install express itself. So I'm just going
to type npm install, express, you can see that
it's downloading right now. And now from here,
let's actually require Express JS into our
project. So I'm just gonna say const. Express
is equal to require Express. Now, when I require
this module, this Express module, what I'm getting
back is a function. So I'm just gonna call that
function. So I'm just gonna say Express. And this
function is going to return an object and this
object is going to have a bunch of methods that
we can use within our application. So let's store
this object within a variable. And by convention,
we will call that variable app. So I'm just going
to say app is equal to express. Now from here,
what I can do is call a method called get. Now the
first argument of get is going to take the route.
So we're just going to say forward slash. And then
the second argument is going to be the callback
function. And it's going to be request and
response. And then all we're going to do is say
res dot send. Hello, world. So this is going to be
our first application using Express. So when the
user visits the route forward slash, what we're
going to do is Sunday response of hello world
and that with a semi colon And then the last step
that we need to do is actually give it a port to
listen to. So I'm just gonna say app dot listen.
And we're just going to listen on port 3000. So
now if I was to save this type no app. And that's
going to run the server, head over to Chrome. Now,
I'm just going to open a new tab. And I'm just
going to type local host 3000. And there you
go. This is our first Express JS application.
And you can see that we got a response of hello
world. And in the upcoming tutorials, we're going
to dive deeper into the Express web framework.
In this tutorial, we're going to work more with
the HTTP GET requests. And we're going to be
talking about Curie string and route parameters.
So to get started, we created a basic Express
application from the previous tutorial. And we
gave it one route, which is basically the index
route, or you could refer to it as the homepage.
And we just said, Hello world. So if I was just
to run this node app, go to Chrome. Go to local
host. And we're going to put 3000, because that's
the port, and you see our basic route. So this
is the forward slash route. So now let's give
it a another route. So I'm just gonna go here, I'm
just gonna say app get. And we're going to give
it another route. And I'm just gonna say example.
And within here, we're gonna pass in a call back.
And now we're just going to say rez, that send
heading example, route. So now if I save this, I'm
just going to hit Ctrl. C to kick us out, we're
going to restart the server, so that it starts
with our newly saved file, head over to Chrome,
hit refresh, you see that our index page is still
working. And if I go here and type example, you
can see that we create another route, and that
it's hitting the example route now, as opposed
to the index route. So now let's go back here,
this is all fine and dandy. Now I want to talk
about Curie strings and route parameters. So I
want to start off with route parameters. And we're
going to create another route. So I'm just gonna
say app dot get. And I'm gonna say example. And
within here, I'm going to give it these colon, and
I'm just gonna say name. And that's going to be
the name of that route. And I'm just gonna say,
ah, and then the same exact thing. So I'm just
going to pass in a callback, I forget to add.
And then this time, what I want to do is access
from the request object. And I'm just going to say
params. And what we want to do is actually print
this out onto the console. Let's see what we get.
And the idea is that I want to get the value of
name. And ah, so we're just gonna say res dot
send. And we're just gonna say hitting, actually,
let's say example, with route params. So we're
just gonna save this, hit Ctrl C, I'm just going
to say CLS, no app, head over to Chrome. We're
going to hit refresh. So our examples working,
but now, we're going to pass information in so I'm
just going to pass in name. So Pedro and an age,
I'm going to put 99. So I'm going to hit Enter.
And you can see example with rope params has been
executed. So now if I take a look back at Visual
Studio code, you can see that when we hit this
route here, and we print out what's within our
request dot params, we get an object. And this
object contains the properties name and age,
and the values of Pedro and 99. So let's give a
more detailed example. Instead of just giving a
generic answer. I'm just gonna print send the
user back his name. So I say name plus Here,
I'm just going to say ah, and don't forget that
this name, property and age is within our requests
that params. And all request dot params is, is an
object. So I could say request dot params dot name
to access the name value. And I could say request
dot params dot age to access the age property.
So now if I save this, and we're going to reset
the server, CLS to clear the terminal node app,
head over to Chrome, hit refresh. And you can
see that we're sending back to the user Pedro in
99. And that we get the same output because we're
still printing it. So that's how we would get data
from the user using route parameters. But there's
also another type of data that you could send
back. And that's called Curie string parameters.
So what is that? Well, if I go back here,
and actually, let me just type this up, I'm going
to say console dot log. And again, we're going to
use the request object because the request object
is basically what the client is sending us. So I'm
just gonna say, request that Curie. And here in
Google Chrome, let's actually cancel this server.
I'm going to save this file, restart the server,
head over to Chrome. Just going to go up here,
hit refresh. Go back to Visual Studio code. And
you can see that we get an empty object. Now this
empty object is going to be our request, Curie.
So it's just a Curie string parameter. And the
reason it's an empty object is because we haven't
actually passed anything into it. So in order to
do that, there's going to go up here, we're going
to use a question mark. And then it's going to be
the name of the property that you want. So
I'm just going to make it up right now. I'm
going to give it a name of tutorial, and then
followed by an equal sign, and then the value
you want to assign it. So I'm just going to say
params. tutorial. And now if I hit Enter Here, you
can see that's pretty much the same thing that's
happening. But if I go back to Visual Studio code,
you can see that our request, Curie object is
no longer empty. We have a property of tutorial,
and we have params tutorial as a value. So now
let's say that I want to pass more than just
the tutorial. So how would I pass multiple query
string parameters. And if we head back to Chrome,
all we have to do is remember to start off with
a question mark, the name of the query string,
and then the value. So if you want to pass in a
second, curious string, what you can do is use
the Add sign or the app or stamp, whatever you
want to call it. And I'm just going to give it
sort. And then I'm just going to say equal. And
I'm going to give it the value of by age. And if
I hit Enter, head over to Visual Studio code. And
you can see now that when we print out our Curie
string, you can see that we get an object that
has tutorial. And it also has the property of
sort. So now you might be asking yourself, when
should I use a route parameter versus a query
string parameter, you should use route parameters
when you must have that data. So for example,
let's say name was an absolute must, I cannot have
a blank name. And I cannot have a blank age. So I
would use a route parameter. And let's say that I
want to give some optional settings. In that case,
I would use a query string parameter.
So for example, when we pass then sort,
we could be sorting the data by age,
and that would be an optional setting,
but I would need the name and the age to begin
with, so I would use a route parameter for that.
And if the user wants to sort the data, then
I will use a query string parameter for that.
In this tutorial, we're going to be talking
about serving static files using Express Now
what do I mean by a static file, I mean, your
HTML files, CSS, client side JavaScript, images,
videos, stuff like that. So to get started,
we're just going to require a path module,
and is basically a utility module that deals
with pass, just to make our lives a little bit
easier. And we're finished here, if I go
down here, I can say app not use now use,
whenever you see app use, it means that I'm using
middleware, the first argument is going to be the
alias for our static folder. So for example, if
I was to hit control B, you can see that I have
a static folder here. And what I want to do is
give this static folder, an alias, I don't want
people outside of my server to know that this
folder is called static. But let's take a look
inside of it. We have an index dot HTML, we have
example that j s. And we have a main dot CSS file,
just for an example. So now if I close that Ctrl
B, I'm going to call it public. That's going to
be the alias for my static folder. The second
argument is going to be a middleware function.
So I'm going to use a convenient method that
express provides us so I could say Express dot
static. And then I'm going to say path dot join.
Say dirname. R stands for directory name. Now,
dur name is a string. And this is going to give
us where app that j s is. So if we take a look,
by pressing Control B, is going to give us where
app dot j s is located. Now I want to go inside
to the static folder, because this is where all my
static assets are. So if I hit Control V, again,
we'll pass in as a second argument, the name
of the folder static. So I'm just going to end
this call in there says there's some error,
and I'm missing a parentheses. So now here,
instead of just saying hello world, let's actually
send a file. So I'm just going to remove this,
say res dot send a file. And we're going to use
our path module. Again, to make things easier.
I'm going to say path dot join, we're going to
give it the directory name that we're currently
in. We're going to go inside the static folder.
And then I want to serve the HTML file. So the
HTML file is called index dot HTML. So now, if
I was to save this, go down here, type node app.
Let's go over to Chrome. Now we're going to go
up here, type localhost 3000. And there you go,
you can see our static HTML file has been served.
If I type f 12. Let's take a look at the source
real quick. I can actually see it. And you can
see within our HTML file that we're using public.
Now remember, we don't actually have a folder
called public, we have a folder called static,
but to the client side is called public. And this
main dot CSS file. Now this main dot CSS file is
working, because you can see that our h1 tag is
red. And now if we go back down here, you can
see public j s and our example dot j s. And if
I go to console, you can see that I printed out
onto the console testing client side. So that's
basically the basics of serving static files
using Express. Now you can use this to use images
and videos, and it'll be the same exact process.
In this tutorial, we're going to be talking about
handling an HTTP POST request using Express. Now
an HTTP POST request is typically used when
working with forms. So I have my form set up
right here. I have an email address field and
a password field and if I was the hit submit,
that would be an example of a POST request. Now,
obviously, we're getting an error from node cannot
post to this route. And that's because we haven't
actually coded anything yet. So if we take a look
at Visual Studio code, you can see our form that I
set up, action is going to be the route that we're
going to code. So I just put forward slash, the
HTTP method is going to be a POST method. Here,
we see that we have our email field, and our
password field, and our button of type Submit.
So now I'm just going to head over to App j,
s. And I actually want to code the app dot POST
method. So if we take a look at our application of
this, it's currently All I have is an app dot get.
This is the route and I want doing is serving the
HTML file to the user. So in order to remedy this,
we're going to use a module that's going to parse
the form data for us. And that module is called
the body parser module. And that module is called
the body parser module. So to get started, we're
actually going to have to install this module.
So I'm just going to come down here, cancel our
server, I'm going to say NPM, install body parser.
So let that install. And now from here, what we're
going to do is require it into our application.
So I'm just going to say Kant's. Body parser is
equal to require body parser. And now from here,
what we're going to do is use middleware. So every
time we use middleware, we're going to call app
dot use. So here, I'm just gonna say app dot use,
then I'm gonna say body parser dot URL encoded.
And then within here, we're gonna pass in an
option called extended. And we're gonna set that
to false. So and that was the semi colon. And all
this is doing is allowing us to parse URL encoded
forms, it parses the data for us and attaches
it to the request body, the extended option is
set to false because we aren't dealing with any
complicated objects. All we want is an email and
password, which are both strings. So now that we
have that set up, let's actually code or app that
post HTTP requests. So we have our get here. And
now I'm just going to go down here. And instead of
saying app dot get, I'm going to say app dot post,
the first argument is going to be the route.
And as you saw on the HTML file, the action
route is the forward slash. The second argument is
going to be a callback function with the request
and rez object. And now from here, remember what
the body parser does, it parses the data for us,
and then attaches it to the body of the request
object. So now what I can do here is I could say
console dot log request dot body. And this is
going to give us an object with the properties
of email and password. And now from here, usually,
when you post something to the server, you usually
use whatever the user inputted, and you do some
database work. So I'm just gonna say database
work, here. And once that database work is done,
you assign a response or user. So I'm just gonna
say res dot send successfully, post that data.
Now, I'm just going to hit Ctrl S to save,
go down here, I'm going to type in Node app,
start up my server. Let's head over to Chrome.
And now if I hit refresh, just to reload it,
let's type some random email. Random password,
hit submit. So now what happened here was I filled
in my email and password I posted to the server,
I got a response back from the server saying
everything was posted successfully. So if I go
back to Visual Studio code, you can see that our
console dot log is working. We're printing out
the request dot body, and you can see that our
form data has been successfully parsed. So if we
take a look down here on to the console, you'll
see that we have an object With the property,
email and its value, and you also have property
of password and its value. So that's pretty much
how you would make an HTTP POST request
using Express and the body parser module.
In this tutorial, we're going to be talking about
how we can handle JSON data using Express and the
body parser module. So in the previous tutorial,
we talked about using the body parser module,
in order to handle URL encoded data. So what
we're going to do is take this form from the last
tutorial, and convert it to post JSON data. So to
get started, I'm just going to head over to Visual
Studio code. And right here, I have my
index dot HTML file and our form pulled up,
what I'm going to do is add an attribute to
the forum. So I'm just going to give it an ID,
and I'm going to call it form. And the reason for
that is I want to prevent the default submission,
I want to post data using jQuery Ajax. So that's
how we're going to post JSON data to our server.
So now that I have my ID, scroll down, and I
already put our jQuery CDN here, just to make
the tutorial a little bit quicker. And we're just
going to go here, and we're going to include our
script. So I'm just gonna say script. Now from
here, we're just gonna say document dot ready.
And the first thing that we want to do is get
our form. So I'm just say dollar sign, pound
sign form. And we're going to attach a submit
handler to our form. And this submit handler is
going to take a callback function, which has an
event as a parameter. So now, what I want to do
is prevent the default Submit. So we're just going
to take the event that we get, and we're going to
call prevent default. And from here, we're going
to use Ajax to actually make the POST requests.
And what we're going to do is post JSON data
back to the server. So I'm just going to say,
dollar sign, Ajax. And this is going to take a
bunch of configuration. So one of the properties
that we can use is called URL, and this is going
to be the endpoint that we're gonna have at our
server. So I'm just going to say forward slash,
second property is going to be type. And this is
going to be what kind of HTTP requests that we
want to make. And we're gonna post JSON to the
server. So I'm just gonna say post. third argument
is going to be the content type. And the content
type is obviously going to be JSON. So I'm just
gonna say application, slash JSON. Next property
that we're going to use is called data. And this
is going to be the actual form data that we want
to pass in. So how do we get the form data? Well,
I'm just going to say, get our form. And then I'm
going to serialize it using the serialize array.
And basically, this is going to take our form
data, so our email field and our password field
serialize it within an array. And this is going to
be a JavaScript array object. But remember, we're
posting JSON back to the server, because that's
the content type that we want. So we're just going
to say JSON that string of phi and pass in this
data as an argument. So this is going to take
the serialized array, and it's going to convert
it into JSON for us. Next, we're going to say
success. And success is going to be invoked when
we have successful response back from the server.
So I'm just going to say response. And we're just
going to print onto the console successfully.
Got response. And we're also going to print out
the response that we actually got from the server.
So once all this is done, let's scroll down a bit.
Everything looks good to me. So I'm just going to
save our index dot HTML file. We're going to head
back to app.js. So this is our server. And
down here, remember that we told our Express
application how to handle URL encoded data Now
what we need to do is just say app dot use body
parser. And this has a method called JSON. Now
this method is obviously going to parse JSON. And
it's going to attach it to our request dot body.
So now if I just put a semicolon there, and when
we scroll back down, you can see our original post
request is handled here. And what I'm going to do
is, instead of saying just plain text, we're gonna
respond back to the client using JSON. So I'm just
going to say, res dot JSON. And we're going to
pass an object. And we're just going to say that
it's been successfully posted. So now obviously,
what res dot Jason does is takes a JavaScript
object and converts it into JSON for us. So now
if I was to save this, and I'm just going to go
to terminal new terminal, and I'm going to say
node app to run the server, go back to Chrome,
when I type localhost. And now to test this
out, let's give it a dummy email and password,
click Submit. And now if I hit F 12, you can see
form serial array is not a function. So let's take
a look at this. And we're getting an error. Let's
actually take a look at that part of the code. And
that's because we did not include the dollar sign.
So let's include that now. Let's save it. Go over
to Chrome. Now we're going to hit refresh. And
type whatever we want. hit submit, go to console
and see that we successfully host that JSON to the
server. A server responded by posting this object
back to us. If I go back to Visual Studio code,
you can see that we have our serialized form data,
you can see that we have our serialized form
data. And that it's not JSON, that this is just an
array. And the reason why you're not getting back
JSON. And it's because our body parser module sees
that it's JSON and automatically converts it to
a JavaScript object. In this case, it's an array.
In this tutorial, we're going to be talking about
validating user input using joy. So what we're
going to do is validate the data coming in from
this form. Now, the reason you would validate user
input server side is because you can never trust
the data that you're receiving from the user. So
to get started, let's actually head over to Visual
Studio code. And I'm just going to cancel out our
server. And I'm going to type NPM, install joy.
And this is going to install the joy module. Now
from here, what we're going to do is actually
require it into our application. So I'm going
to go up here, I'm going to type const, Joy is
equal to require joy. So now that we have joy
in our application, let's actually go down to
our request. So we have our GET request, which
basically serves the form to our user. And we have
our post request, which is going to get the data
from our user. So from here, what we want to do
is actually validate the data that we get within
our request body. And in order to do that, what
we're going to do is create a schema. So what's
a schema, a schema is basically a blueprint,
a set of rules that we want our data to have.
So we have an email field, and we have a password
field. So what I want to do is make sure that the
email that the user gives me as a valid email, and
likewise with the password field. So what we can
do here is I can come down here, and we can create
a schema. Now remember, this is just a blueprint,
I'm going to say joy dot object. Now this is going
to give us a joy object. Next thing we need to do
is call a method called keys. Now keys is going to
work the same way that a regular JavaScript file
would work. You will have your key value pairs,
and we're going to pass in the options. Now within
here, what we want to do is set the rules that the
data that we're receiving must follow. So we have
a field called email. And within here, I'm gonna
say joy, I'm going to say string. So what I'm
saying is, the email field must be a string value,
I'm going to trim that data that I'm receiving,
I'm going to call a method called email. This is
going to check to see whether or not this is a
valid email. And I'm going to call one more method
called required. Now required does is if the user
sends me a no email, in other words, the user
doesn't fill out an email, I'm going to get an
error because this field is required. So let's
go back to our another property. And the next
property we have is password. So from here, I'm
going to do the same thing, joy, I need it to be
of type string. And let's change it up for the
password field. So let's say that I need the
password to be at least five characters. So I'm
going to call the min method and pass in five,
I'm going to call the max method. And I'm going to
pass in 10. So right now, this password must be a
minimum of five characters long, and a maximum
of 10 characters. So between five and 10. And
the last method I'm going to call is required.
And now let's end this with a semicolon. So now
that we have our blueprint, let's actually
use it. So we're going to call a method
called validate. So I'm just going to say joy dot
validate. And it's going to take three arguments,
the first argument is the object that you want to
validate. In this case, remember, we use the body
parser to parse the form data and attach it to the
body of the request object. So this is going to be
our first argument. The second argument is going
to be our blueprint, which we just created, it's
called schema. And our third argument is going to
be the callback function, that's going to take two
parameters. First one is going to be error, second
one is going to be result. And what we can do is
find out our result. So if I say if error, this is
going to execute true, if there's something wrong
with the data, so error is not know then this
code will be executed. So if error is executed,
we know something went wrong. So I'm just gonna
say res dot send, an error has occurred. But if
there is no error, what we can do is we could just
say res dot send. And I can say, successfully,
post that data. Now just for the sake of this
tutorial, I'm going to print out result, just so
you can see what the result is. Now, the result is
basically just going to be the data that we passed
in. So it's just going to be the request body. And
I'm going to go up here, and I'm going to print
out the error object. So now that I have these
two out, what we can do is get rid of our old
code from the last tutorial. I'm actually going to
save this, we're going to type in Node app. Let's
head over to Chrome. And from here, I'm just going
to type in, actually, let's just refresh the page
real quick. Let's type in an email. And let's
type in a password. And then if I hit submit,
you can see successfully posted data. So if I go
back to Visual Studio code, you can see that our
email is right here. And it probably hit Submit
twice because I probably clicked it twice. And
you can see that our result that's getting printed
out is just the request that body is whatever the
user posted. And you would do all your database
manipulation and calls here. So now let's actually
go back to Chrome. And this time, we're going to
type localhost again. And stead of giving valid
data. Let's see what happens when we post invalid
data. So I'm going to post valid data for email.
And for the password. Remember, we have to give
it between five and 10 characters long. So I'm
just going to give it two characters long and
let's see what happens. I'm going to hit submit.
And you can see the response we get an error has
occurred. So let's actually take a look at this
in Visual Studio code. You can see this big long
mess of mumbo jumbo So I'm just going to go back
up. And you can see the error that we're getting.
It says validation error child password fails,
because password must be at least five
characters long. So you can see our validation
is working. And this is pretty much the ins
and outs of validating user input using joy.
This is going to be part two of my joy
validation tutorial. So in this tutorial,
we're going to be covering how we can validate
a nested object, as well as how we can validate
an array. So to get started, I pretty much
stripped out all the Express stuff. And we're
going to simulate a user's requests. So for this
example, we have this user input, and it has a
nested object. And it has a property of personal
info with the properties of street address, city
and state. And we have preferences, which is going
to be our array, and you can see what values their
array contains here. So the first values that
we're going to start off with are string values,
and then we're going to move on to objects. So
the way that I'm going to tackle this problem is,
I'm going to look at our user input, and I'm going
to break it down into sections. So for example,
I'm going to develop a schema for personal
info, and then I'm going to develop a schema
for preferences. So to get started, we're going
to develop the personal info schema, first, I'm
just going to copy this, I'm going to come down
here. Now I'm gonna say Kant's, personal info,
and then I'm just gonna add schema. Next, I'm
going to create a joy object schema. So I'm just
gonna say joy dot object. Keys, we're gonna hit
enter a semi colon down here, we're going to go
up copy street address, would just develop a
schema like we normally would. So I'm just gonna
paste that street address is going to be joy dot
string, dot trim, I'm going to make this required,
we're going to do the same thing with the other
properties, go to city, copy this, go down here,
paste, and street address and city, we're going to
make the same exact thing. And last but not least,
we're going to take the state. And it's going to
be the same exact joy schema, except that we're
going to add that it has to be of length of two.
So I'm just going to copy this, paste this here.
And we're going to use the dot length method
and set that to two. So we're going for state
abbreviations. So now that we have our personal
info schema out of the way, let's develop a schema
for preferences. So I'm going to copy this, we're
going to go down here, I'm going to say Kant's,
preferences, schema. And this time, instead of
using joy dot object dot keys, we're going to say
joy dot array. And this is going to give us an
array schema. And we're going to use a helper
method called items. Now what items is going to
take in as an argument is basically any schema you
want. In this case, what we want is an array of
strings. So I'm just going to pass in the schema,
Joy dot string. So this is going to make sure
that all the items that within their array are
off strings. Last but not least, let's actually
combine these two to form one schema, I'm gonna
say Kant's schema. And I'm gonna say joy dot
object, dot keys, pass in this object. And this
time, we're going to say personal info. And that's
going to be equal to the schema we just created up
here. So we have our personal info schema. So I'm
just going to copy this, paste this here. And now
if I go back to my array, we call it preferences.
Copy that has this here. Preferences schema. Next,
let's actually call this so I'm going to go
down here, I'm going to say joy that validate
the first argument is going to be the same as last
tutorials. So we're just going to say user input.
second argument is the schema. So we're going
to use the built in schema Now that we made,
which consists of the two different schemas
that we created separately, last argument is
going to be the callback function. So I'll just
say error result. I'm going to say if error,
we're just going to print out what the error is.
Else, just print out the result. And the result is
just going to be the user input. So I'm just gonna
save this, let's actually add a semicolon here,
save this, we're gonna type in Node app. And you
can see that our data is validating. So the basic
premise is, if you're given a complicated
object, break them up into their individual
schemas. And then you could combine them like
so. Now I want to talk about, let's say that I
want an array of objects as opposed to an array
of strings. So we're just going to go up here,
we're going to change preferences to reference
array of objects. And then we have an example
object here. So this is a very simplistic example,
we just have a property of code example. And it
has the value of a string. So example, one, two,
and three. So we're just going to change this
through an array of objects. Let's go down here.
And instead of specifying joy dot string here,
because we're not looking for strings anymore.
We can say joy dot object, that keys and then
we just build our schema, like we did before.
So in this case, we only have one property,
it's called example. And we're gonna
give it the value of joy dot string,
dot required. So this was a very simplistic
example, if you had a more complicated object,
you would do the same thing like we've been doing.
So I'm just going to save this. And let's actually
execute this code, see if it's working node app.
And you can see that it validates, and we didn't
get any errors. So that's basically how you can
develop a schema for nested object, and how we
can develop schemas for arrays, and even create
our own custom schema objects for those arrays.
In this tutorial, we're going to be talking about
e j, s. Now what ej S is is a template language.
And that's going to allow us to write more dynamic
web pages. So to get started, what we have here is
a static HTML file, you can see that we have dummy
data here. So when it says you searched for stuff,
and we have search results of dummy data, now
what we want to do is use this HTML file as
a template that we can use for serving dynamic
data. So one way to do that is if we go back to
Visual Studio code, we can set the view of our
Express application. And in order to do that,
we would go here, and we could say, app
dot set is going to take into arguments,
we're going to specify the view engine, a second
argument is going to be the template that you
want to use. So we're just going to say e
j, s. Once we set the view engine to ej s,
we're going to have to hit Ctrl B. And we're going
to have to create a folder called views. And this
is going to store our E j s templates. So I'm just
going to go down here, right click New Folder,
and we're gonna call this views. Now Express is
going to automatically know that our templates
are located in the views folder, because that's
the default folder that looks for. So now if I
create my views folder, if I right click new file,
and instead of saying index dot HTML, I specify
index dot e j s. So now that I have my index.js
file, I'm just going to go to my index dot HTML.
I'm going to copy all this. And I'm just going to
paste the code within my index dot e j s. So now
I'm just going to save this. I'm going to go to
App dot j s. And what we do with templates is that
we've rendered on to the user. So I'm just going
to hit Ctrl B and get rid of the package explorer.
And instead of sending a static file, this is
going to remove this and now we're going to say
res dot render And then followed by the name of
the file that you run to render index. Now, you
do not need the specified a dot e j s on the side.
And that's because we already told express that we
are using ej s as the template. So now if I was
to save this, just gonna hit Ctrl C, node app,
head over to Chrome, we're going to hit refresh.
And you can see that we get the same exact output.
So what happened here? Well, when we render this
index.js file, what's happening is the server is
going to look at this E js file for e. js code,
it's going to execute it and then send back to the
client an HTML file. So now let's actually send
data to sun back to our E js file. So from here,
I'm just going to give us a route parameter,
I'm just going to say user query. And here we're
going to pass in an object. And this is going
to be the data that we want to display within
our index.js template. So now I'm just going
to give it a property. First, I'll say data,
then I'll give it a property of user query. And
then we're going to pass in request dot params dot
user query. So now if I save this, I'm just going
to hit Ctrl. C, just to exit out of our server.
Now we're going to go to our E js file. We're
gonna go here to our template. And now from here,
we're going to specify less than or sent sign
equal. What this means is I want you to output
onto the HTML file. Next, what we're going to do
is access the data that we just passed in. So how
did we do that? Well, we gave it the property
data, then we said, dot user query, afterwards,
we end it with percent sign, and then that. So now
this is gonna look at our app dot j s, it's gonna
say, Okay, I want to render the Index page. And
this is the data that I'm receiving. So we went to
data dot user query. So now if I was to save this
index.js template, let's start back to server,
no to app. Let's go to Chrome. Hit refresh. And
you'll see that we get cannot get forward slash.
And that's because we added a route parameter.
So let's say the user searched for books,
for example. Then it says, Hey, you search for
books. So imagine if this was a real website,
and we were on Amazon or eBay, you would do
a search. So then on top of that web page,
you would get Hey, you searched for books, you
searched for PCs, you search for whatever. So
that means I could use this ej s template for
all the items within my website. So now, let's
actually add some dummy data. So if I go back to
Visual Studio code, and what we're going to do
is instead of having hard coded stuff here,
when the user types in, we searched for books,
we're gonna display a bunch of books. So I'm just
going to go to App dot j s, we're going to pass
in more dummy data. So we have data user query,
we're gonna pass in another thing. And I'm just
going to give it a Enter key to make it fit on
one line. And we're going to pass in an array,
and this is going to be the search results.
search results. Pass in an array, and we're
just going to say, book one, book, two, and Book
Three. So now if I save this, go into my index,
e js file. Instead of saying dummy data, what we
can do is, we could go to data, because that's the
object that we're passing in. We're gonna say
search results. And then since it's an array,
we can access index zero. And this is going
to give us our first position. And remember,
since we this is an E JS template, we're going
to have to wrap this up within the following.
And now if I was to save this, let's go SQL Server
restarted up, go to Chrome, hit refresh. And you
can see that now we're dynamically populating the
web page. So now let's head back to Visual Studio
code. And what I want to do is, instead of just
outputting data that search results that index
zero data that search results index one, what we
can do is use a for each loop. So for example,
let's get rid of all this. And I started
with that, we're going to pass in less than
percent sign, we're going to get our array. So
what's our array at data, that search results, dot
for each, we get our result. And remember, we're
going to end this with a percent sign less than,
and the reason why we don't have an equal sign
here is because we are not outputting this onto
the HTML file. So for example, if I want to output
this equal sign, if you don't want to output it,
no equal sign. Next, within here, what we're
going to do is, we're going to display what
we want to output. So now what we're going
to do is use less than percent sign equal,
because we actually want this to output to
the HTML file. So I'm just gonna say, oh, II
result. And let's close our Li tag. So now we
have to end this. So we're just going to end
it with percent sign, we're not going to use the
equal sign because we do not want to output this
to the user. So now, if I was to save this, we can
go down here Ctrl C, node app, go to Chrome, hit
refresh. And you can see that our search results
gets dynamically added. So if we search for books,
and there was a million books, this code will work
for a million books. If we searched for iPhones,
and there was only three types of iPhones, this
code would work for three iPhones. So now let's
do an example involving conditionals.
So we're just going to give a simple if
statement. If the user is logged in, we want you
to display this, if the user is not logged in,
then we're not going to display anything extra.
So now if I go back to Visual Studio code,
let's write an if statement underneath our
h1 tag. So I'm just going to go here. I'm
gonna say this. If data logged in, and this is
going to be a Boolean containing true or false,
but and this here, and now the meat of our if
statement is going to be the HTML output that we
want to do. So now I'm just going to say h2. You
are logged and as data dot username and sent sign,
and then let's close our h2 tag. Now we have
to wrap up our if statement. So let's close
our if statement. And all we're going to do is
do the following ecgs. close our if statement.
And remember, we're not using the equal sign
because we're not wanting to output this. And
we're not using the equal sign up here because
we don't want to output this if statement. So
now if I was to save our index.js file, let's go
to App dot j s. And we're going to pass in those
properties that we added to our index.js file.
So we passed in logged in. And for this example,
we're just going to set true and the username is
going to be this. So I'm just going to go to index
that ETS just to see if we matched up properly.
Otherwise, we're going to get an error. logged in
username here. Make sure everything matches up.
Let's save this Ctrl C, node app. Head over to
Chrome, hit refresh. And you can see that since
we are logged in, we're displaying our h2 tag,
you are logged in as so. And so if we set that
to false, our h2 tag wouldn't appear. So that's
basically the ins and outs of how you can
use ej s within your Express application.
In this tutorial, we're going to be talking about
what middleware is, and how we can create our own
custom middleware. So middleware is basically the
code that gets executed between the user request
and the server itself. Now, in the previous
tutorials, we already used a middleware, and
that middleware was within the body parser module.
So if we take a look at our Express application,
on line five, we say app dot use, and then as
an argument, we pass an A function. And this
function is a middleware function, that when the
user makes a request, this function will take the
user's request and process it. In this case, the
body parser dot JSON function checks to see if
the user have sent any JSON data, processes that
and then attaches it to the request dot body. And
then it calls a function called next, to let the
server know that, hey, we're done processing this
request, you can send a nother request. So to
get started, we're just going to go down here,
I'm going to say app use. And then we're
going to pass in our own middleware function,
that's going to get executed whenever the user
makes a request. So this should be very familiar,
we're going to pass in the first parameter is
going to be the request object, their response.
And then the final parameter is going to be the
next method. So now we already are familiar with
the request object and the response object. So
what is this next method, this next method must be
invoked whenever you create a custom middleware.
So what the next method is responsible for,
is to let Express know that, hey, I'm finished
processing this request. If you do not call the
next method, what's going to end up happening
is you're going to timeout the server, because
it has no idea whether or not you're finished
processing that request or not. So right now,
I'm just going to say next, and we're just going
to call it. And to make things a little bit more
interesting. let's actually go up here. And
I am going to print out the request, that URL
and the request dot method. So now, if I was to
save this, let's actually restart the server,
I'm just gonna hit Ctrl. C, node app, we're going
to go to Chrome. I'm going to hit refresh. Now
when I hit refresh, what I did was make a get
request to the server. So let's actually take a
look at Visual Studio code to see what happened.
And you can see that our middleware is running.
So we made a request, it gives us the URL, it
gives us the method of the request. So we made a
get request when we hit refresh. And then we said
next, which let Express know that, hey, he's done
processing this. And then it got to this point
where we just sent res dot send middleware onto
the user. So that's why you see that we got this.
Now let's change this up. So instead of saying,
forward slash, because we got to get route there,
let's just make something up. Now, if I hit Enter,
you can see Can I get whatever this route is,
but that's okay, because we're not interested
in that. We're only interested in the middleware
for this tutorial. And you can see once again,
that our middleware is running fine. So
whenever there's a request made from the user,
this middleware function is going to get executed.
And you can see that our route was printed out.
And the type of request was also printed out onto
the console. Now, this is all fine and dandy. But
as we have it right now, whenever we use App dot
use, and we have our middleware, any user request
is going to get processed by this middleware.
Let's say that I only want this middleware to
execute when a certain route gets requested. So
right here, I'm just gonna go here, and I'm just
gonna say example. This is gonna be our route.
And now, whenever we call this example, route,
it could be any type of request, that could be
a get request, post request, put, elite, doesn't
matter, this middleware is going to execute. But
if it doesn't match this example route, then it's
not going to execute. So let's save this. And I'm
just gonna hit Ctrl, C, node app, start this up
again. And now I'm just gonna hit refresh. Go back
to Visual Studio code. And you can see that our
middleware is not executing. But if I go up here,
type example. Go back to Visual Studio code. And
you can see that our middleware is executing just
fine. And the last thing that you should note that
middleware functions can do is modify the request
object and the response object. So going back to
our body parser example, it parses the user's
request and searches for JSON, and then attaches
it to the request dot body. So to give a trivial
example, I can say take the user's request,
and I can add a property called banana. And I
could assign it the value of banana. And for the
sake of simplicity, since we already have this
route here, we're just going to get rid of all
this. And within our get route, we're just gonna
say, console dot log requests that been then. So
let's end that with a semicolon. Let's double
check everything. And this looks good. So I'm
just going to save this. And we're going to
restart the server. Now, the app, we're going to
go to Chrome. And we're going to hit our root. And
there we go. If we go back to Visual Studio code,
you can see what's going on here, we made a
request to the server, the server did some
processing the same thing that body parser did,
and then adds to the request object. And in this
case, we just added banana, gave it a value of
banana. And then here, when we got the request,
from our get route, you can see that we get the
output of banana. So that's pretty much the ins
and outs of how you can create your own custom
middleware, and how middleware works in general.
In this tutorial, we're going to be talking about
the Express router. Now what the Express router
allows us to do is separate our routes into
different files. This makes our code a lot more
manageable, as opposed to just sticking our routes
within the app dot j. s file. So to get started,
I'm just going to hit Ctrl B to bring up our
Explorer, I'm going to create a new folder to
store our routes. So I'm just going to right click
here, new folder. Let's call that routes. And
we're going to create a new file called people.
So this is where we're going to store our our
people routes. So I'm just going to hit Ctrl B
again. And since we're using the Express router,
we're obviously going to need to include the
Express module. So I'm just going to say const.
Express is equal to require Express. Next, we're
going to call Express dot router, which is a
method that's going to return to us a instance of
the router. So we're just going to say that within
a variable. So I'm just going to say Kant's route
is equal to express dot router. So now that we
have our router instance, what we can do is setup
our route. So we already know how to do that. So
I could say route back get. And we're just going
to give it the path. And we're going to give it
the callback. So the request object response. And
we're just going to say res dot send forward slash
being hit. Now let's just create a another row.
So I'm just gonna copy this. For example, and I'm
gonna call this example. And let's say example,
being hit. Now, we're not done yet. So right now
we have this route here. But how do we expose this
route so that our app.js file can access Well,
in order to do that, we're going to have to use
module dot exports. So I could go down here,
type module dot exports. And then we're just going
to export this route that we created. So now I'm
going to save this, we're going to head back to
our app.js file. And now down here, we're going
to have to actually require the people route. So
how do we do that? Well, I'm going to create a
variable called people. And we're just going to
require the file. So I'm just going to say dot
forward slash, I'm going to go inside the routes
folder. And then I'm going to include our people
file. But we're not done yet. Remember, on line
three, we created an express application. So now
we need to tell our Express application that
we want to use this people were out. So let's
go down here. I'm going to say app dot use. And
we're going to give it the base URL. So I'm just
going to say for slash people, and then we're
going to pass in the people route as the second
argument. So it's going to pass on people. So
now if I was to save this, head over down here,
node app, let's go to Chrome. And I type localhost
Port 3000. And that's because we do not have a
base URL. Remember, we gave it people. So this is
our base URL for this peoples row. So right now,
this forward slash would be accessed if I just
typed people at the end of localhost. So I'm
just gonna add that people. And now you can see
our four slashes being hit. And if I add another
forward slash, and do example, you can see our
example route is being hit. So now what happens
if you want to add middleware to these routes, so
I'm just going to go back to Visual Studio code,
we're going to go to our people route. And within
here, I could say route.us, and then pass in our
function, our middleware function that we want
to execute. So I could pass in my request object,
my rez, and next. And now I'm just gonna say,
console dot log middleware being used. Now when
I use route that use, all requests is going
to go through this middleware. So remember to
always call next, if you ever creating your own
custom middleware. And now if I was to save this,
let's hit Ctrl C, node app. When I go to
Chrome, hit refresh. And you can see that
our middleware is being used here. Now, this
middleware is only going to be used within our
people out. If we had another route here. Let's
say instead of people we had an animal route,
this middleware is obviously not going to
get executed because this middleware is
only specified to work with our people route.
So that's pretty much the ins and outs of how
you can use the Express router to actually
separate your routes from the app.js file.